in particular algebraic tools for
sampling learning optimization and data
analysis
high dimensional geometry randomized
linear algebra and computing for good
um he has many awards including being a
fellow of the ams the american
mathematical society acm fellow um
sloane research fellow
um formerly was a miller fellow more
than 20 years ago here at uc berkeley
and uh let me not i can go on and on
about awards so let's just stop here and
i'll hand it off to santosh for the talk
thank you hunters
not much uh welsh in this talk but there
will be some more uh
uh there will be a lot of randomness um
so here's the
i have only 26 slides which is the fewer
than the number of minutes i have so
hopefully this will be on time um
so here are the two problems minimize
the function let's think of euclidean
space we'll see something more general
very soon
uh
and generate points from a distribution
whose density is proportional to e to
the minus some function of x okay
those are the two problems
uh so before assignments in fact in the
20th century we had great results
optimization can be solved to polynomial
time
logarithmic in the desired accuracy
polynomial in the dimension for
arbitrary conducts
functions
and also
you can sample basically f is convex
you can sample e to the minus f
uh with in in polynomial time
approximately
great right so the polynomial time
setting in some sense at least for
convex
problems was understood
now these problems don't really have any
reason to be associated right you're
optimizing you're finding one point the
extreme in some direction and then
sampling you're kind of getting a
distribution
except there is this one result which
says that convex minimization can be
done by a polynomial time reduction to
sampling so you can reduce one to the
other not quite the other way around but
you can do it in this direction
okay
so
uh let's go
forward a little bit and see so more see
more precisely what what these what
these bounds are
so for optimization the general convex
optimization problem
the
the way you present it is how do you how
do i get this function or the you know
we so
um you get it through
an oracle either a separation oracle or
a membership oracle and in either case
so in the case of a separation article
with n calls to the separation oracle
and poly n additional time you can solve
the problem so the way this would work
is
basically you maintain
a set of possible
points where the solution might lie
and then you try to query a good point
so that no matter what the separation
oracle gives you you're able to reduce
the set of candidates by a
constant factor so that's what you can
do with the cutting plane method the
ellipsoid algorithm was weaker it was
cutting it down by one minus one over n
factor but
you can actually cut down by a constant
factor so it takes you
order n iterations to to zoom in
uh with a membership article it takes a
little bit longer it takes poly n calls
because you don't get this benefit of
telling you that oh your solution is on
this side of a hyper plane you just are
told no this is not it you're not you're
in or out you get a yes or no answer
okay so
in september 2013
uh this guy at the first simon's program
this young graduate student walked into
my office and asked me started asking me
questions about convex geometry and
telling me these things indeed
a couple of years later
they had this improved result on this
classical problem
still maintain the n calls to the
separation oracle but you need only n
cube total time
this is the state of the art
it was very much done here simons
uh and uh
in a couple of years later we also got a
uh what's called the current best so n
is the best possible you can prove
information theoretically you can't do
better than that a
simple proof and
n squared is what you need for the
membership oracle again it's probably
time but we don't know if it's the best
possible so here's open problem number
one can you do convex optimization with
fewer than n squared
uh membership oracle calls
it's an oracle model right so there's no
issue of turing machines or yeah
okay sampling
um you know
20th century 21st century so the
algorithms are are even simpler
um you have basically a markov chain a
random walk one of the simplest ones is
uh at a current point you consider a
little ball around the current point of
a fixed radius delta you
try to go there if the point is still in
the set you're trying to sample from you
go otherwise you try again if you turn a
sample from a distribution then you look
at the function values where you are and
where you're trying to go look at the
ratio and that tells you with what
probability you should accept you should
write distribution the the metropolis
filter
okay and so kanan lowest and shivan has
proved that n to the five queries you
know these these in or out or function
value queries suffice for the first
sample and then cube for later samples
they already proved this in 97. the
first one takes longer time because you
need to do a lot of setup but then after
that it's enqueued
uh and then they made a conjecture let's
say that that would imply and this is
the the entire motivation of the
connector that n squared suffices for
latest amps same algorithm just the
analysis
requires this geometric conjecture which
if true would imply n square
later samples
uh what does that mean that means that
you basically have a very good start
so you have a you have what's called a
warm start your distribution is with
is is pretty close to what you want to
sample from so
that's one and the second one is that
the density is isotropic so the
covariance matrix is the identity it's
not arbitrarily skewed
okay
that was in 97
just last year
we're able to improve this to n cube for
the first sample
and
as of uh last month
it turns out that the kls conjecture is
true up to log n to the five
and this implies it's n square times
log to the 10 and for later samples i'm
ignoring all log factors unless they
depend on other parameters here
so uh
so up to logs which
at this point maybe
are not important uh uh it's n squared
for later samples
okay
we'll
the words kls will keep coming up but
yeah that's the thing now question
is this the best possible not for this
algorithm but in general again we're in
an oracle model because we're asking
membership queries is n squared the best
possible for sampling let's say
uh
it's open
okay
uh now there are two related problems
that i'm only going to spend one slide
on which are motivating and also help
you
help those problems a lot uh
the first is volume
and the second is integration more
generally your integrative given
function
and so you can do these things in
polynomial time
uh
volume of a well-rounded body you can do
an n cube steps
uh this happened post assignments
the rounding problem in case you haven't
seen it before is just to find a fine
transformation that makes your
distribution have mean zero and
covariance close to identity okay
and so
uh
the result of this paper i mentioned
last year is that the rounding itself
can be done in cube and therefore using
the
existing volume algorithm everything's
enqueued
is cubic the best possible for volume
computation not clear
okay
okay so why is it so slow why are we
talking about this quadratic in cubic
factors right
um the bottleneck is the step size both
from the optimization and in
sampling it's like how big a step can
you take so in the in the sampling case
it's how large of a ball can you use to
make your next steps
and
the problem is that you're kind of
forced to take a ball
whose radius is not too large
let me see pen okay
um so basically
if you had a cube
um
yeah right and um
you know how if you take a ball point
somewhere near the boundary
and you consider a ball around it
right well most of us is outside so
you'll be spending all your time on
wasted calls
so you have to make your ball about one
over root n and then for most points you
will spend a constant fraction of the
time actually going to a new point
okay so so that's the bottom like one
over root so you've got to take these
tiny steps and your diameter is root n
so ends up taking n squared even for a
cube
and n squared is the bound for all
bodies now okay so um
so then you could say
you know why don't we take d you know
bigger steps
when you're deeper and smaller steps
when you're closer i mean you know it's
pretty obvious right but if you try to
do that
what will happen is that okay here great
you have a big step
right oops
um
okay you know
yeah you know you will remember this
like it or not
so in the middle oh great big step
then you come here you take a smaller
step
and then you come here and you take a
smaller step
what's going to happen to the
distribution it'll just go stick to the
boundary
okay you don't get what you want okay
so
can we use the local geometry in a more
meaningful way right and this question
will come up in both questions both both
problems
and so let's go to optimization where
this has been used very successfully for
a long time so what's the difficulty of
optimization i'm only talking about
convex optimization there's nothing uh
non-convex here is that well you have
let's say let's say linear you have this
direction you want to minimize so just
go that way right like like gradient
descent or gradient would tell you
problem is you hit a hard constraint
and then when you hit a heart constraint
you kind of have to adapt so you try to
go along that you hit it again again and
again again and that's what happens with
something like simplex you just
you take too many steps right it
wouldn't be nice if you could somehow do
this continuously right like you
basically pretend you're a little ball
and you're just rolling down towards
this target and you just get there like
something is we should be able to do
that right yeah okay so um that's the
difficulty of optimization these hard
constraints convex optimization
smooth strongly convex functions where
you don't get these sharp
boundaries hard boundaries r is are in
fact much easier to optimize okay
and you know um
this is this newton iteration which sort
of
you know
where you use the hessian inverse times
the gradient to take your step
if in case you've never seen this before
you know if you're
if you spend your life in the boolean
world then you know
all this is saying
i love it but you know
here is here is the you know we take a
function write down a degree two taylor
approximation and then that's a
quadratic right and then you ask uh
what's the best step i can take if i if
i knew this was my function
well you take the gradient set it to
zero and you get that this is the best
step you can take
so that's how this is this is this was
this is the newton iteration right great
so but this session is crucial how the
gradient changes is crucial i will use
that to define your local geometry right
so when you have a hessian it gives you
the ability to define a local metric
because the function is convex it's
always positive semi-definite so this is
a well-defined norm for every point
great
so the integer method
which
you know uh you'll see what i mean by
why it's the same thing as designing
designing a
rink
is is is the following idea
i hope the animation works let's see
oops oh yeah good
so um
uh so what we'll do is instead of
minimizing your function f which is
convex but could be non-smooth
let's add to it uh uh uh what's called a
barrier function which is going to be
very well behaved and and smooth it will
do two things
first it will blow up near the boundary
okay
um
ignore this for a second
so so let's say that's your set
and what this function does is at a
current point it looks at the distances
to the boundaries
and the simplest of the barriers already
incur markers work is uh some sum up the
negative logs of the distances so as the
distance goes close to zero this goes
off to infinity okay so and you add this
to your function so it keeps you away
from the boundary if you're away from
the boundary it seems much better right
so you don't hit these hard constraints
and you have to change course
drastically you could just keep going on
a smooth path so that's your function
that's what we'll do start with some t
that's large say one that way you have a
nice function you can optimize it using
just the neutron iteration and then you
gradually reduce the t
uh at this rate one minus one over root
nu if you could do it at that rate you
would get root new iterations up to log
factors
but you need one more property what is
this new
what this new is capturing
is
is is the fact that the hessian of your
phi
you know
is going to define an ellipsoid for you
a little ellipsoid for you
okay it's the it's it's your local
metric so it has this ellipsoid which
you can prove always lies completely
inside the body but but then the
question is what scaling of it contains
the symmetrization of the body around
the point i'll draw a figure for this in
a second but it's it's sort of measuring
house how
how well does the hessian approximate
the local geometry
okay um
we'll see in a second but so that's the
key parameter here new how well does it
approximate the local geometry and you
go at that rate 1 minus 1 over root 2.
so this this path of where you optimize
this for each t is the central path
and so the function looks like this it
just blows up near the boundary
and you want to design it so that the
change is not too high
but at the same time
you know it's computable and efficient
okay so the so that that's property one
how well it approximates locally
property two is the fact that the
hessian should change slowly so if you
think for a second as the of the local
metric essay identity so this is just
like you're looking at a ball
then this is saying that the change in
any direction of the hesitant is bounded
is it is no it's it's a lip [ __ ]
function it's growing as much as the
length of light
okay so you should the question
shouldn't change too fast
that's that's the property you'd like
okay
with these two properties at hand
you get spectacular results and many of
them in the last decade
so this is i'm illustrating here what
the what this uh
capturing the local geometry means for
current point x in the set you look at
the reflection of the set through the
point that's the two x minus k and
that's your ellipsoid and a scaling of
it contains contains the entire
intersection
okay so how how so what functions can
you do can you uh exist you want to find
good good barriers
so the one i already mentioned is the
log barrier and for that the parameter
is m the number of constraints this
markers work so give you a square root m
iterations
the universal barrier which was
introduced from namorovsky uh actually
has only n doesn't matter how many
constraints there are you can define it
for any kind of export it doesn't have
to be a a linear program or a polytope
and it's it's n
n is the best possible in general and
there are other barriers that give you m
as well however computing them is
actually
not no it's not very efficient back then
they didn't even have an algorithm for
computing universal barrier because it
involves computing the volume of a
convex body
now you can but it would be a very slow
way to do optimization
okay so
something that happened much of the work
here right here at the at the simons
institute is that uh lee and sidford
define what's called a weighted log
barrier
which uh gets you uh
a parameter of o tilde n so with a with
a log m vector
and it's very fast
okay it's very fast just as fast as the
log barrier and therefore you only need
square root and iterations
if this this was an open problem in
optimization for a long time and it was
solved
very much by the tcs community in the
simon's environs
now here's the question can you do fewer
than root and iterations this is not
just a question about optimization it's
really a complexity question can you
solve linear programming
what's the parallel depth of solving
linear programming
so we've heard this result that linear
programming is uh
uh p completed right i mean what we're
asking is can you do linear programming
with fewer than root n
uh parallel depth
you know
smaller than root in parallel
okay that's that's open
um
now
so that's a number of iterations and
each iteration is one linear system
great okay you're getting our linear
system that's a problem we studied quite
a bit uh
uh however in spite of the fact that it
looks like root 10 linear systems
a surprising result cohen lian's song
three years ago is that linear
programming can be solved actually in n
to the omega time
just matrix multiplication time you
don't even need the root n times this
now matrix multiplication time shows up
because that's the time to solve a
single linear system that's our current
best time to solve a single linear
system
okay so
uh even though you need to solve root
and
linear systems they're managing to do
all of it in one the time of up to logs
time of one linear system
how is this possible
and
the the main observation is that the
solution to this linear system it's
they're not completely different linear
systems they're all linear systems that
you get by changing the constraints
that you're considering a little bit
they you argue that the solution changes
slowly and you only need to compute the
significant changes and you can actually
do that with an amortized dynamic data
structure
yeah and this has become
a great field and so on we already we
saw a talk about a
breakthrough like yesterday or how this
this type of idea can be used to
to to get max flow and nearly needed uh
almost linear time
you you know i for till
till late last year i didn't know the
difference between almost nearly how
many people know the difference between
almost nearly
okay so let me explain to the rest of
you
almost means
n to the one plus
little one
nearly means n times polylog
it's a huge distinction in the world of
uh you know fast algorithms okay um
now
so linear systems are the bottleneck now
for optimization at least for linear
programming
so let's go to that and ask
it's a basic problem right we should
know how to solve linear systems
but it's an open problem we don't know
how to solve them faster we only know as
fast as matrix multiplication which is a
great problem but you know it has its
has its whole set of complexities
um we as far as we know it could be ends
quadratic
because certainly the representation
size of the answer is quadratic
you don't need less than that i mean
because you need n bits potentially for
an n by n
system
uh in fact linear programming could be
faster than matrix multiplication
um
and so last year with richard peng we
managed to show that at least for sparse
linear systems not not terribly sparse
fewer than n to the omega minus one
divided by log of the condition number
non-zeros
you can solve it faster than matrix
multiplication
and in fact you can solve faster than
matrix multiplication no matter how how
fast you make matrix multiplication as
long as it's more than two
so if okay so if tomorrow
virginia
williams tells me that it's
n to the 2.01 we can still solve linear
systems faster but
only for sparse enough
okay uh so this is just an indication
that there's something else out there
that we haven't figured out yet how to
solve a linear system
okay so back to sampling what is it
where does this show up in sampling
so
how do we use local geometry for
sampling right this is this was the key
point we were able to use local geometry
to do optimization fast
um
so instead of sampling from a ball let's
sample according to the local ellipsoid
and then use a filter to make sure you
get the right distribution
and indeed kanan and narayanan
showed that this deccan walk
mixes in mn steps
and each step you have to solve this
equivalent of a linear system again
um
now this is the best possible this is
tight for this for this result
um
there's a figure that should show up
sorry there that's what the dick
involved looks like now let me go back
here
um this uh
so a generalization that we
got a couple of years ago uh is that in
fact it mixes in n new steps where new
is that parameter of the barrier
function so instead of the dick in
ellipsoid for the log barrier you can
use any barrier you want and if you have
a better barrier you get a better bound
and so on
so in particular using a weighted log
barrier you can get n squared steps you
can get quadratic number of steps for
mixing regardless of how many facets
there are in your
defining your politic
okay um
curiously the kls conjecture
implies that the universal and entropic
barriers are both also going to give you
this quadratic rate just
now here's an open question does this
weighted dicken walk we proved quadratic
but as far as we know it could be linear
and we don't know whereas just dicken
the mn is tight for weighted dicken when
you use the weighted log barrier it's
possible that it's just linear
we don't know the answer
okay
so then
we see we're still back to quadratic
right we're still at quadratic and the
reason again is the same it's a step
size we can't make these ellipsoids too
big even though you have this ellipsoid
here you actually end up taking a step
from an ellipsoid that's about a one
over root and scaling down of it because
if you take bigger than that what
happens is that the the ellipsoids
change too much and the probability that
you make a real step becomes too tiny so
you end up hitting this one over root
and bottleneck again
in a different form
okay so you change an m to an n but
you're back to quadratic
so um we found out about this method
at a simon's workshop actually a
workshop for which i was the lead
organizer but i never heard of this
method before but and then we found out
this beautiful method from physics been
around for a long time uh hamilton in
monte carlo
and what it says is that
don't take straight line steps you're
using local geometry already why do you
have to be so brutish and do these
discrete changes make a make a
continuous step you know if the local
geometry is changing continuously your
step should also be a curve why should
it be a straight line
okay and so what it says is you pick a
direction v
and then you're going to move in that
direction according to an a differential
equation
which preserves some function what
function and physics the normal function
is some potential plus kinetic energy
type of thing uh f x plus half v squared
but you can do this with local geometry
and so you can do this uh with a general
metric so g here represents some metric
it could be the hessian for barrier for
example
and and you get this as your hamiltonian
using just that setup there you get to
preserve the hamiltonian as you move
and now you pick a random direction each
time
you've got this walk now
will this give us a chance to take
bigger steps bigger than this one over
root n right
and so just to make sure the the process
is clear at the current point x you pick
a random direction according to the
metric ellipsoid given by the current
metric
and then you move not in that straight
line but according to this ode which is
like a
path in some manifold okay
okay
so
uh the answer is yes you go below
quadratic
you can probably you can take steps
still polynomial but it's one over n to
the one third now it's a fruit n
okay uh so and um each step is still a
linear system
now for the log barrier
with this method on on the cube turns
out you only need polylog steps
and this is the first method to need
polylog steps on the cube the cube is
easy to sample so that's not a challenge
problem but uh yeah
okay
so was that three minutes joining yeah
okay great so um
uh
here are some questions related to this
can we use dynamic data structures to
reduce the per step cost totally open
for sampling it was great it's been it's
been very successful optimization
not at all clear whether it's helps for
sampling what's the best metric to use
and what's the right careless conjecture
in this manifold setting
okay in practice it turns out that you
always have constraints say x equal to b
so
one can adapt the method to this the
reason i'm putting this up is because of
the theory versus practicing
you get a very practical algorithm
and so whereas in theory i already
sketched this current state of the art
this is the state of the art theory
in uh practice you can go to this
sampler it's publicly available uh and
try it out
and
you can go literally up to a million
dimensions and sample it it's now been
incorporated into the systems biology
package called cobra which is used for
these large metabolic systems analysis
and uh
you you know it performs uh
orders of magnitude better than
than the previous methods that that that
take local steps straight straight out
um on a variety of benchmark data sets
um yeah if you have trouble it's the
right way to say it is crunch so yeah
okay okay um anyway um so here's the
model they built for this this is a
a
a huge number of reactions and
metabolites existing packages either
don't work at all or um
you know
yeah they can't handle constraints and
you can actually run it
on your laptop or my laptop
okay so
um
the last view we're going to talk about
is a
view that let's let's go back even more
really sampling
is optimization in the right space
okay so this is also a view that came
partly out of berkeley so this paper by
jordan kinder otto
and and and popularized by ruby sonos
that longivian diffusion
is in fact gradient descent you see how
similar those those steps are so we're
talking about purely continuous methods
the first is gradient descent the second
line joint diffusion
but you're in the space of measures so
each point is a measure
and your target your objective is
relative entropy
okay
how about using local geometry you can
use romanian language diffusion and you
get a similar such process
uh i will skip
um
this
a very active field many results here
there was a simon semester uh last year
um
[Music]
but and and finished off with
the kls conjecture itself on which
there's been tremendous progress
resulting in in in all these fast
algorithms
and uh one could ask does it matter you
know now log n versus constant besides
being mathematically nice and implying a
bunch of dimension different constants
here's a concrete tcs reason the kls
conjecture implies certifiable
subgaussianity
which means that you get sos proof sum
of squares proofs
of moment inequalities
for log concave densities as opposed to
just
gaussians this was in the work of
kothari and steinhardt and um
yeah so so getting a constant is very
important log means you still get an end
to the log pep algorithm as opposed to a
polynomial timeout
um
are these equivalent does certifiable
subgaussianity imply kls i don't know
but up to log it's trivial
because it implies thin shell and thin
shell is within log of kls okay
uh i'll conclude with one conjecture
um
made with low voice a long time ago i
don't know exactly when it would imply
the kls conjecture and this is a
combinatorial conduct it's almost
combinatorial for any isotropic convex
body and any decomposition of it into
cylinders you give me an arbitrary
decomposition of the cylinders what do i
mean by a cylinder it's just something
that has a small cross section and one
axis any any convex cross section
a constant fraction of cylinders must be
short
so it's not possible to take a convex
body
and break it up into cylinders so that
uh most of them are long you must have a
cosplayer and that implies careless okay
i'll stop here there's a bunch of nice
questions one can ask about what to do
but maybe this is my favorite do you
even need randomness to estimate the
volume of a deterministic
offer of an explicit polynomial
yeah thank you
oh yeah here's the meta algorithm sorry
[Laughter]
find the right space find the right path
find the right discretization i made
this slide just in case manuel showed up
but he's not here but i'm sure
thank you
why wouldn't i hope for sure i hope for
it
sorry
yeah yeah so instead of the end to the
two-third uh what about the proof like
obstructs you from going to root n let's
say right so we have to bound a certain
curvature tensors norm
and uh all the methods we know how to
bound it
don't let us go beyond n to the two
third
so is that the reality i don't know as
far as i know you you could do much
faster than that
any other questions
i think since it's being recorded let's
wait for the mic just so that it gets
captured
so i want just to clarify the last slide
and probably one of the slides in the
middle of the talk so
in the middle of the talk we say that
kls conjecture has been solved
not up to log n absolutely conjecture is
that it's it's a that's a geometry for
any log concave density is it isotropic
concrete is an absolute constant so can
you repeat again what is happening well
um
so you
present it that
there are some specific consequences if
we achieve n squared uh if we achieve
constant events yeah yeah yeah so
right now that we have the
the result up to a logarithm yeah so up
to logarithm for the purposes of the
analysis of algorithms uh instead of
quadratic we get quadratic times polylog
for sampling so so maybe that's not so
important but uh for uh for this uh
result that i mentioned about uh
clustering mixtures of distributions
uh using the sum of squares approach
um
it's important that uh you establish
proofs of these moment inequalities
higher moments are bounded by a certain
function of a second moment to the power
of power at this moment with
with the sum of squares proof
and so what uh kotari and steinhardt
were able to show is that it's not it's
in fact turns out to be quite quite
quite a simple proof now um that the kls
conjecture implies
that you get this certifiable
subgaussianity for arbitrary log concave
distributions as opposed to just
calculus for which we know
and now that we have it until again
doesn't give us anything because the
running time would be n to the log to
the five oh
okay thank you thank you very much
okay if that's it then
let's think santosh again